guys congratulations top 11 narrowing it
down to top 10 this week be honest how
much are you guys trolling Blake seeing
that he's trailing behind you know what
that's a good idea we need to actually
be more active in doing that don't you
think John turnabout because last season
when we did the cross battles he was
like dominating every round and he had
three people out of four in the finale
so you know he's been floundering the
entire season he's totally a loser this
season no what happened is she's his
weakness that's that's actually what's
happening I was gonna say he's better
he's got to keep his fingers crossed
because that might make for an awkward
dinner conversation at the Thanksgiving
table this week I have to say though he
is one of my favorites on his team cat
is yeah she blows me away every single
time I'm still so mad that she's on my
team cat and Ricky are both very strong
so all friendly and all loving at the
dinner table this week speaking of the
holidays Thanksgiving
this week what are your guys's plan all
I can think of is probably what he's
eating I'm not but it just dawned on me
that you're gonna have the best
Thanksgiving ever
hi we are - we're probably going to be
doing a cheetah's Turkey which is who's
who's cooking in your household we all
cook actually my mom we all fly out to
Oklahoma it's like 30 of us so it's
gonna be pretty busy because I'm like oh
yeah and we have lake house like this
bed-and-breakfast hotel that we all stay
at and it's just pretty incredible it's
like this old 150 I don't know how old
it is but it's old and as we have fun we
all cook together and so it's fun
do the kids cook at your house Luna
helps she begs to help I was like that
when I was a kid too I was always so
curious what my mom was doing in the
kitchen and I was like I want to stir
something I want to do this and Lunas
the same way she loves it she loves
hanging out with her mom in the kitchen
I hope in the kitchen - it's like a
family affair
and we don't like potluck though we
don't like people to bring stuff we're
like we got this
I mean you have all your families
together then you're they're gonna come
up to a Southern California we rented a
house in Palm Springs yeah did you get
the invite can we go coaches over for
dinner and then very near future
you guys haven't done it yet not yet we
will the Halloween but we were I was in
Vegas we didn't cook for that though
we'll have a I got to give you a huge
congratulations this week you are
performing a medley from your debut
album I cannot believe it's the 15-year
anniversary of that album already what
do you remember most about that chapter
in your career I just remember being
really terrified to like step outside of
like my band and riding with new people
like because we were from like the olden
days where we just did our thing in our
garage like it was nobody was
interfering there was no we started
working with producers and that was
scary enough but I just I didn't even
know there was like this circuit that
you could write with people like I
didn't even know that existed and so to
be able to go and do that and like have
this very clear like artistic like
vision of what I wanted to do it was
like oh we're gonna take a break oh I'm
gonna do this like I just I wanted to do
a dance record like because I grew up in
you know a time period where music was
just like it was just so incredible you
know and I wanted to make I wanted to be
Debbie dead like I won't be Lisa Lisa
coach Jam like I wanted to do all that
so I tried well you succeeded and in
celebration of her big anniversary this
month with the 15 year anniversary of
the album can you give me like maybe one
of your favorite lines from one of the
tracks I mean we got hollaback girl we
got rich girl I want to get him another
fun love about first of all I loved all
of that music and it was so good and we
all danced to it and my favorite thing
to say was ooh that's my that's my
ooh that's my that's my that's pretty
way cooler than I thanks to you we all
know the proper spelling of the word
bananas now guys thank you so much
actually one more question for you
before I let you go obviously you know
2020 is rolling around and Kellie's kind
of here essentially passing the
residency torch to her do you have are
you sure like I was saying like how are
you gonna do that but she's like oh you
know I actually texted her I was like
are you out of your mind
and she was like no no I like this I
like maybe I think and she's like I love
my talk show but I want to do music and
so she I'm excited for her it's a really
different from anything that I've ever
done like it's just not the same as
touring it's not it almost reminds me
what it would be like to be on Broadway
or something you know I mean um because
it's such an intimate crowd and and
people coming from all over the world
and it's just a different energy and I
am just feel so blessed I think also it
was a really like amazing time like to
put it all down and put it into a show
like as therapy for me but I think
Kelly's gonna really enjoy it and and
it's I can't believe I did it I only
have like 15 more shows left so I'm
gonna I'm starting to get that like
bittersweet like I can do 15 more but at
the same time I'm gonna be sad when it's
over really quickly any advice for her I
think she just needs to make sure she
puts hand sanitizer on her stage and
like keeps it clean because I if so many
it's it's Vegas like there's a lot of
germs so you got to be careful like keep
the voice you know it's dry humidifiers
you put it real I love it going so funny
yeah thanks we have to deal if you deal
with other stuff so yeah thank you guys
so much
[Music]